LARRY WHAT ARE YOU
COOKING UP FOR TONIGHT.
>> OH HEY, JON, I WAS WORKING
ON MY MARCH MADNESS BRACKET
OVER HERE, YOU KNOW, JUST TRYING
TO MAKE THAT BIG MONEY.
>> Jon: MY TOO, WHO DO YOU
LIKE THERE? WHO DO YOU LIKE?
>> Larry: OKAY I'VE GOT KENTUCKY
WINNING THE WHOLE THING.
>> Jon: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
KENTUCKY, ABSOLUTELY.
ALTHOUGH WHO, YOU KNOW, FOR THE
SEMIS WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
>> Larry: WISCONSIN, DUKE
AND VILLA NOVA.
>> Jon: WISCONSIN, DUKE, AND
NOVA, YES, YES, YES.
>> Larry: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
>> Jon: YES. YES.
>> ARE YOU JUST COPYING MY
BRACKET?
>> Jon: NO, WE'RE IN THE SAME,
WE'RE IN THE SAME POOL,
IN THE SAME COMPETITION,
WOULDN'T IT BE FUN IF
WE WON TOGETHER?
THAT WOULD BE FUN.
>> Larry: NO, NO, NO.
JON, I WANT TO TAKE YOUR MONEY,
OKAY.
SPECIFICALLY YOUR MONEY.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHAT THEN FINE
I'M NOT GOING TO TELL HELP YOU
BY TELLING PEOPLE THAT YOUR
SHOW STARTS RIGHT NOW.
>> Larry: YOU JUST DID, HA,
HA, HA.
>> Jon: SON OF A BITCH,
WILMORE.